So when she's pregnant, when she's
conceived, what is that that's growing
inside her?
>> A baby. But if it doesn't have a
heartbeat yet,
>> so okay. So if somebody doesn't have a
heartbeat, but they're living on a on a
support machine, right? They don't have
a heartbeat, though. So you need a
machine to pump the body to pump oxygen
into the body. Is that person still a
human? What?
>> No. If they're not talking, they're not
human.
>> If they're not talking, they're not
M. It's
got the
It's got the
>> Okay. So, um, what did you guys want to
talk about first?
>> Uh, that you guys think abortion is
murder.
>> Yes, 100%.
>> Why do you think that?
>> Because it's a life, right? So, when
you're ending a life, especially um
without its its decision, without, you
know, uh, you know, it has no no voice
of its own. When you're terminating that
life, you're ending that life. That's
murder. You're killing her.
>> I understand that. But what if a girl
gets raped?
>> Well, okay. Let me ask you a question. I
just want to ask a quick question. Okay.
So, uh, if we would take a deal and say
that all abortions
should be illegal except for rape cases,
would you agree to that?
>> No.
>> Okay. So, then why are you even asking
the question if that was not even the
point? You're talking about all
abortions, not just rape cases. You're
just trying to use the marginal cases to
justify the rest. Why even bring up rape
cases?
>> That was one part of the That was one
part of the question. There's like moms
that are not financially like ready for
it. There's like if you're too young,
like it's not only rape.
>> I got you. Okay. So, let let's let's
deal with these situations then here,
right? Um the mom can't afford to have
to to support the child. Um stuff like
that, right? So, if a mom is not able to
support her child, let's even say uh an
infant baby, right? Her newborn, right?
Let's say it's like 2 days old. Should
she be able to end that baby's life
>> after it's born? No.
>> Why not?
>> Because that's an actual living thing.
Cuz after you give it, like you take it
out, it's an actual living thing.
>> Okay. So, what is in her belly before
it's born?
>> A fetus. That's not alive.
>> So, how is it growing?
>> Like through the mom, like
>> Yeah. How is it growing?
>> It's just growing.
>> So, it had to be alive to grow, right?
>> Yes. But the mom's alive, so she's
taking care of it. Without the mom,
there is no baby.
>> Okay, good. Without the mom, can that
two day two day old baby survive?
>> No.
>> So both So no notice both. You even
realize it. Look, I love it. I love But
we're here to do that, right? We're here
to to to get understanding. So you see
the problem there, right? That both the
ba the infant newborn can't survive
without the mother. Neither can the
unborn child. They're both in the same
predicament. The the only difference is
the location. One is outside the womb,
one is inside the womb, right? So it's
no difference. There is a difference
because also to have the baby it's like
the mom goes through a lot of things.
It's easy for you to say cuz you're a
man but as a woman
>> a man.
>> How dare you assume my gender?
>> You assume I'm a man.
>> Are you?
>> Okay. Now that's respectful.
>> I'm definitely a man.
>> I just listen to you.
>> What were you saying?
>> No. So you were saying uh that there
definitely is a difference between the
unborn child and the newborn. Yeah. And
you said, "I can't speak of it as a man
because women go through it a lot."
>> I mean, you're allowed to speak on
whatever you want because you have free
will, but like you don't deserve an
opinion.
>> But what if what? So, so wait, just real
quick, I'm I'm married, by the way. So,
if my if I'm if my wife gets pregnant
with my baby, you mean to tell me that I
don't have a right to speak on the life
of my baby?
>> Cuz you're not having the baby. So,
>> I am having a baby.
>> That was not You're not actually having
the baby. I am. You don't go through the
things. You don't go through.
>> So who So who the who the baby daddy?
>> You can be the baby daddy, but you don't
go through the things that like to be
like
>> So you mean to tell me that I don't have
to deal with the stress of my wife when
she's pregnant nagging me for snacks and
I got to wake up early in the morning
and deal with her attitude and carry her
up the stairs.
>> That's your choice for picking a woman
like that? Like
[Applause]
transpired.
>> Look, look. So, so this is where we're
at, guys. So, with men, you're right
that we are not the ones that get
pregnant. However, we're the ones who
impregnate. And the father has every
right just as the mother when it comes
to decisions about the we're a team. She
didn't make the baby on her own. We both
did. So like for example, do you think
that do you think that fathers are wrong
for abandoning their their pregnant uh
baby mom? Do you think they're wrong for
her?
>> Yeah. Yeah.
>> Why?
>> Because like I guess it's good to have a
father figure, but there are a lot of
women that don't have dads that still
pursue a very good life. No, I agree
with you that there are single mothers
that are thriving. They're doing their
thing. However, it's Can we agree that
it's good to for a father to be there
for the woman she he impregnated?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So, that means that because the as
the father, they're supposed to be there
to support the woman through that
pregnancy. I can't abandon her. So, we
are both in this together. Not just
after the pregnancy, but during it, too.
Not just when I'm laying with her, but
once she's popping that belly, I'm there
with I'm there for her. I'm taking her
to the hospital. I'm the one who's
carrying her up the stairs. If I'm the
one rubbing her feet, I'm the one doing
my best to make sure that this process
is as smooth as possible. Is Isn't that
a good thing?
>> Yes, but you're also emotionally there.
She's like act physically there.
>> We're both there. Do Do you know that
sometimes both the man and the woman
gain weight during the pregnancy? Yeah,
that's I mean that could be a thing, but
again, she's gaining weight for the
baby, not for you.
>> Right. And I'm gaining weight because
I'm just outside of this, you know? I'm
I'm I'm helping my wife and I'm losing
my physique. But that's the sacrifice
that the man makes because he's there,
you know,
>> become her.
>> Exactly. So So here here we are. It's
good for a father to be there. So a
father is there to support his his wife
or baby mom and they're supposed to be
there to have to support the baby. So
they have a right on the say both of
them. It's a team effort.
>> I understand it's a team effort, but the
mom physically goes through the stuff
that she has to to have that baby. Like
gaining weight, throwing up, like she
could die having the baby. The man does
not go through anything like that. Of
course, yeah, they have to take care of
the mom and the baby emotionally, but
there's nothing physical that you're
going through.
>> Okay. So, tell me this. It's okay to
kill a baby when
>> she gets raped. The mom is not
financially ready or is there anymore?
>> She's too young.
>> Just
>> she's too young. Like
>> too young.
>> Yeah. 123.
>> 123. Okay. So if if if she's raped, if
she if the mother is if if the mother
can't support the baby and uh if she's
too young, abortion is okay.
>> Oh, I have one more. Also, if like the
mom's about to like die and she's going
through stuff, then she should have a
baby.
>> Okay. So she could she could right she
could preserve her life. So that
wouldn't be an an abort that's her
preserving her life, right? Okay. So
that that wouldn't count, right? We're
talking about perfectly healthy woman
who, you know, had the choice. They had,
you know, slept or whatever. They're
adult. Her health is not in in the
question. You're So you're saying rape,
too young, or inconvenient
>> financially?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. So I'll ask you the question
again.
>> Okay.
>> So if the baby if the newborn is
inconvenient to her mother, should she
have the right to kill her baby
>> at a certain time? Yes. I feel like
>> even the newborn.
>> Oh, the new baby if it comes out you're
done. Like
>> so what is the difference? That's that's
what we need to get to. What is the
difference between the newborn that like
let's for example the day that the baby
is born and then the prior day that it's
still in the womb. What's the
difference?
>> Because the difference is it's living
like off of its mom. It's not breathing
actual oxygen. Like also
>> it's still breathing oxygen.
>> I know. But like through the mom, not
through its own mouth. Like
>> Okay. So again, so we're talking about
what what the baby is um leaning on for
life support basically.
>> And we both agree that without the
mother, the newborn cannot survive.
Correct?
>> Yes.
>> So should she be able to kill the baby?
>> I mean, if she gets raped, a smart
>> No, I'm talking about No, not forget the
rape.
>> It's inconvenient. Financially, she
can't support it. Should she be able to
kill her newborn?
>> Her like her she had it.
>> She had the baby. She can't support the
baby and the baby can't live without
her. Should she be able to kill the
newborn?
>> No.
>> No. But the thing is in the beginning
stages of pregnancy, I'm done. Not done
talking.
>> In the beginning stages of pregnancy,
it's not really like an actual baby. And
I understand that you have a different
opinion. And in my opinion,
>> what
>> what is it?
>> It's I'm I not I don't mean to like say
it's a clump of cells, but it really is.
It's not really like
>> a clump of cells that made what?
>> What's growing in there? a baby. Like I
don't
>> You just said it's not a baby.
>> It's not a baby yet. Like
>> so when does it become a baby?
>> I mean I don't know the actual like six
to four weeks. I don't know exactly that
but I'm saying like in the beginning is
the right time to get an abortion. I
understand if it's like an older like
not like an older kid but like a more
like grown baby inside.
>> So stage of development is what you're
saying determines when
>> Okay. So when at what stage of
development does the does what's growing
inside her become a baby?
>> I don't know exactly the time.
>> Okay. Is it a human growing in her?
>> I mean, what what do you mean?
>> Is there a human growing in the woman?
>> I mean, yes, but in the beginning, no. I
mean, like, in the beginning, yes, but
it gets to a point that like
>> it just grows. It develops.
>> Yes. I agree.
>> Okay. So, so you have you have stages,
you have stages where the baby is
developing, the human is developing, but
at all these stages, it's still a human.
It's still a human baby, right?
>> In the beginning. Beginning.
>> Yeah. In the beginning.
>> No. Heartbeat. Does it have a heartbeat?
>> It doesn't It doesn't have to have a
heartbeat for it to be a human, right?
Yeah, it does.
>> Okay. So, do do humans give birth to
non-humans?
>> Huh? Do humans give birth to non-humans?
>> No.
>> Okay. So, when she's pregnant, when
she's conceived, what is that that's
growing inside her?
>> A baby, but if it doesn't have a
heartbeat yet, like, you can't see.
>> So, do you do you see how you keep
shifting? Now, it's about the heartbeat.
So, okay. So, if somebody doesn't have a
heartbeat, but they're leaving they're
living on a on a um on a support
machine, right? They don't have a
heartbeat, though. So you need a machine
to pump the body to pump oxygen into the
body. Is that person still a human?
>> Yes.
>> But they don't have a heartbeat.
>> They're not alive. No.
>> They're not alive.
>> No. Until they're alive, they're human.
>> So that person who is un life support
who is whose life is still going because
of a machine. You're saying that they
stopped being a human.
>> What do you guys
think?
>> I think they're still alive.
>> He's still alive.
>> He's still alive. So are you still
human?
>> In the hospital in life.
>> Yeah.
>> So are you still a human? Yeah, they're
still human.
>> You agree?
>> I don't believe that now.
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait. What?
>> No. If they're not talking, they're not
human.
>> If they're not talking, they're not
>> So, they're human.
>> Do you agree?
>> I mean, you're asking like, wait, what's
your exact question? Cuz you keep like,
>> okay, here here's my thing.
>> What I've what I've determined from
y'all's answers is that you guys your
answers shift depending on what you're
considering a human to be or a baby to
be. So when you give examples like, oh,
it needs to have a heartbeat for it to
be a human. Well, we literally have
humans that don't have a heartbeat that
live off of machines. But would you say
that they're not human anymore because
of that?
>> Yeah. Living off the machines, they're
human.
>> They're still human.
>> Yeah, they have a heartbeat.
>> No, they don't have a heart.
>> They don't have a heartbeat. So they're
dead, right?
>> No, they're not dead either cuz the
machine's keeping them alive.
>> So yeah, they're alive. They have life
support.
>> Okay. So if they're alive, they're still
human.
>> Yes.
>> So guess what? It's a life support
pumping a heartbey. Like you need a help
to that. Like you need
>> No. So it's it's pumping oxygen into
them. Sometimes you you have some life
support systems that like uh that do
keep the heart, you know, pumping, but
the heart is not pumping on its own. So
them themselves, they don't have a
heartbeat. It's the machine that's
pumping it for them or pumping oxygen
into them for for themselves.
>> But it's still beating the heart.
>> Yeah. In some situations. Yes.
>> Yeah. So then you have a heartbeat cuz
you're still liable because of the
machine.
>> Yeah. But is that their own heartbeat or
is it the machine?
>> It's the machines. But it's still like a
heartbeat that's happening for them.
>> Now, so notice this. So in the same
situation with the mother, with the
mother, is the heartbeat is the
heartbeat dependent on the baby or is it
dependent on the mother?
>> Dependent on the mother.
>> Exactly. So in both situations, look
look in both situations, the grown adult
human and the unborn baby are both on
life support. They're just in different
situations.
>> The life support is from the mother.
Other life support is from the machine.
>> Yeah. But we don't have the same
opinions as them. Like
>> Okay. Oh, don't move them. Yeah. Right.
Right. Right. Yeah. We we let's throw
them under the bus then. Okay. Okay. So,
all right. So, back. So, so back to you
guys. So, do you guys understand do you
guys understand that in both situations,
the baby is on life support of the
mother. The other human, the adult human
is on life support of a machine, right?
Should they kill the human being who's
on life support of a machine?
>> That's not their choice to make.
>> Not their choice to make.
>> Very good. It's not their choice to
make. Look, we're getting somewhere.
It's not their choice to make. Now,
>> these questions are like, "Yeah, wow."
>> But these questions are good.
>> I understand. But like, let's get to the
root of the problem. Not like
>> here is the root. Look, the root of the
problem is this.
>> It's not their choice to make. It's that
person's choices on life support, right?
Who that person has a it's their choice
if they live or die. That baby, the
unborn baby, it's another human being
that is on life support of the mother,
but it's their choice for them to live,
right? not anybody else's to infringe on
their choice and just kill them. Now,
unfortunately for in both situations,
neither the unborn baby or the adult on
life support have the voice to speak for
themselves. They need us. But
unfortunately, people are sacrificing
these unborn babies and killing them
without their voices.
>> So, that's why we're here doing this.
It's wrong to infringe on their choice
>> depending on the circumstance,
>> depending on the circumstance. So, as
long as the mother's life ain't a ain't
a ain't, you know, ain't threatened.
Yes.
>> Then the baby should be there's no way
we should decide.
>> I agree. I agree.
>> Amen. Amen to that, sister. Now, we got
to work on her now.
>> Amen. I'm glad you agree, sis.
Excellent. So, so what do you think so
far?
>> I think that like it just depends on the
circumstance. Like, there's so many
things that a woman has to go through. I
understand the whole like machine thing,
but it's just like not like it's just
not reasonable. Like, get to the root of
the problem.
>> What's not reasonable?
>> If a girl gets raped, she has every
right to. She's not financially like
she's allowed to do whatever she wants.
I understand like the b like imagine
that like the baby does get born, right?
And she doesn't get an abortion and
she's not like financially ready to take
care of the baby. That baby's going to
grow up with a living hell of a life.
You rather that than just a easy take a
pill or something and like have an
abortion.
>> What what I'm what I'm saying is is that
we have examples, sister, of people who
are products of rape. people who are
born of rape, who have thrived in their
life, who have grown to grown out of
that struggle, and they're even, you
know, preaching on behalf of unborn
children. They're going to these places
and they're saying abortion should be
illegal. I'm a product of rape myself,
and I'm glad I'm alive.
>> You could say the same thing about
serial killers. They could have like
they got raped, their mom got raped,
they had the baby, and that baby turned
into a serial killer. You can't use that
example as that.
>> So, so then here we are. Are you saying
that um people who are like what what
determines how a person's life goes in
life? Is it how they're born or is it
the choices they make?
>> It's both to be honest. You could have a
really good family and be a bad person.
You can have a bad family and be a good
person.
>> So really it's up to you, isn't it?
>> Yes. But you're saying that like famous
people like their parents almost had an
abortion, but then they became great.
But you could say the same thing about a
family, they were going to have an
abortion, but they kept a baby. Then the
kid became crazy and killed.
>> So notice how it doesn't matter. It
doesn't matter. It depends on how that
person chooses to live their life.
>> They can grow up and make decisions that
are for the greater good as a human
being or they can make decisions to
prove that they're morally corrupt. But
that's on them. It has nothing to do
with their mother being raped. It has
nothing to do with their mother being
unable to provide for them. There are
people who have grown up in foster
systems that have grown to be great
morally great people and vice versa.
People grow up in the foster system and
be morally bad. It doesn't matter. It's
upon us individually.
>> Yes, I understand that. But some there
is a still a percent chance that like
foster like that whole program is like
really hard. Like it's not like easy.
Some people
>> So is growing up rich.
>> I mean I guess so. Yeah, I guess so.
>> People growing up rich they they they
become detached from people. They uh
they bully folks. they have they they
grow up without empathy for others or
for those who have less. Right? So you
can say the same for those who grow up
rich that it's hard for them to be
morally acceptable. A lot man a lot of
these people they they we see them on uh
uh How Did I Murder My Wife? We see a
lot of these rich folks on these type of
shows, you know, like that's how it
depends on the individual and their
choices,
>> right?
>> But I do have something to say like you
earlier you were like, "Oh, that the
person that their parents couldn't had
could have had an abortion. They could
have been something great." You made
that point, but now you're backtracking
because of what I said.
>> No, I didn't. I didn't backtrack. What?
>> No, you were earlier. You said those
people become great, but And then I said
those people become bad. Then you
started saying what?
>> No. So I didn't say that all of them
become like great people. I didn't say
that. I'm saying that there was there's
some among that group, that category
that grow up to be good people. That's
what I'm saying. So
>> Okay. You're trying to give me a look at
her. But I I guess uh I guess we got an
understanding now.
>> Yep.
>> So are you still for a person?
>> Certain circumstances. Yes. Yes, I stand
by what I think.
>> Okay. Do you still think that if a if a
woman cannot financially support her
baby that she's has the right to do it?
>> Yes.
>> Dang, that's cool. It's okay. But this
was I appreciate the conversation. This
is awesome. Let's let's give it up for
the sister guys.
>> If you want to go ahead.
>> Um, so who said that life starts after
the baby is born, right?
>> I mean, I'm not exact cuz I'm still
young and I'm still learning, but I
don't know the exact time. But keep
going.
>> Where's Chloe?
So basically you're saying that the the
baby only matters the life of the baby
only matters after the baby is born
right
>> I guess so I mean it depends actually
like considered an actual
>> um reason for it to live
>> like the mother can't kill the baby
after it's born the teacher says
>> no wait wait wait hold on those programs
are not always like really good you know
>> Hold on hold on
>> so you're saying that when the mother
when the mother gives birth to the baby
that she can't murder the baby, but she
can murder the baby when the baby's
inside, right? I mean, in my opinion,
like it should be in the early stages if
you can, but if you can't, like if you
really are in the point of your life and
the baby's still growing and you need to
have an abortion, I think you still
should have it. And you're saying that's
well that it's a fetus. It's a compass
cells. It doesn't necessarily. So, my
question for you is if a person comes
and murders a pregnant woman, why in the
justice system it says is a double
homicide?
because that wasn't her choice to get
murdered.
>> I I know, but like the
>> Was it her choice to get murder?
>> Yeah, I understand it wasn't her choice
to get murdered, but if it's her baby,
she didn't ask the murderer to kill her
baby. Like, that's not her problem.
>> So, now it's the mother just murdering
the baby.
>> That's okay, though.
>> It's It's okay for the mother to choose
to murder the baby, but nobody nobody
else to murder the baby.
>> Yeah, because that's not their body.
>> She said yes, y'all.
>> It's not their body.
>> Neither is the baby. It's a It's a
double No, it's a double homicide.
>> Homicide, meaning two two people died.
>> Two two bodies are murdered. Yeah. So So
the person who killed the person who's
pregnant is not being charged with
killing two people instead of one.
That's what a double homicide means. So
if you're saying necessarily that life
like the mother can only, you know,
>> Sorry.
>> No, you could.
>> Okay. So about that.
So if you're saying that the mother can
only consider murder if she kills the
baby outside of the womb. If a person
kills a p a pregnant woman inside of the
womb, why is it considered that they're
killing two people? A double homicide.
That's my question.
>> That's the thing. I'm still young and
I'm not very educated on that. And I
would love to get educated, but I that's
just not like something
>> that's a fair that's a fair point, but
hopefully you took this as an
educational standpoint, right? A double
homicide is when two people die, whether
they're in the womb, whether they're
outside of the womb.
>> Dad, you're religious, right? No. Okay.
Oh, yeah. She's religious. You're
Muslim, right? You guys have souls,
right?
>> So, you don't believe if you're
religious, you don't believe a baby.
That's at conception. That's when it's
alive. Has a soul itself. You're killing
a soul.
>> It's a soul.
>> Yeah. I I am Muslim and and everything,
but there are like that's the thing like
I know abortion is murder and stuff like
that, but that was also in the time that
like the books were created a very long
time ago before like abortion really was
like like as experienced and like well
done as it is today. Like I understand
where your viewpoint, but like
>> Okay, so so just to wrap this up, hold
on guys. So just to wrap just to wrap
this up cuz you know we got to move on.
>> Yeah, that's that's beautiful. So one,
you're very humble with your your like
you admit like oh I want to be educated.
Your humility is beautiful. So yeah I do
think that you're like the more you grow
and have the same attitude that you can
grow in these areas. So when it comes to
double homicide if you're thinking about
that does that kind of change your view
a bit on what you're considering to be
human or alive or or have a have value
to life? Like how if if it's considered
double homicide, it's two bodies that
are that are that are dead.
>> I mean I guess so. I I mean I guess so.
But the thing is, like if a random guy
kills a lady that's pregnant on the
street, like that wasn't her choice or
the baby's choice. But when it's like
the thing is when it's like her baby,
that's kind of like her own blood, her
own like skin, like everything. It comes
out of her, so it must be her choice.
>> But but it's not her skin, though.
>> I mean, it's like 50% of like her,
though.
>> It's not. The baby has its own skin, its
own body part.
>> Yes. They're not attached, but like, you
know what I mean? So you're saying that
the baby can have a should infringing on
the baby's choice is wrong in one sense,
but it's not wrong to infringe on the
baby's choice. And when it comes to the
mother,
>> I mean, think of it like your parents
raise you, they give you rules. Like
it's almost like until you're 18, like
they rule over you. It's
>> Yeah, but they can't kill me or else
they'll go to jail.
>> Yeah. I mean, I guess so.
>> You know, so what I'm saying like it's
their a parent a parent raising me is
their duty as a parent, right? It's it's
their duty. It's their duty to raise me,
to to groom me, right? It's not their
duty to to uh, you know, cause me to
perish, right? Notice if if if if uh
there are parents that starve their
children or don't feed them or leave
them at home or keep leaving them at
school, they get charged for negligence,
right? They're it's their duty to take
care of the child. So it's it's just
mindboggling to me how we can switch to
these are this is how we're supposed to
handle our children then but when it
comes to the unborn child all of the
sudden those responsibilities don't
apply all of a sudden the baby has a
choice and it's murder and double
homicide in a car accident or but when I
choose to kill my baby uh it's it's not
a life that makes no you see how the
logically this position doesn't hold you
know
>> yeah the inconsistency
>> it's inconsistent The inconsistency here
is that I hope that I pray that you take
this with you, right? It's one of the
things that you said that a feed a baby
is just a feas compass cells when it's
inside the body. But the justice stages
right like I feel like if it gets to a
point where like the baby is starting to
fully develop like get eyes, get ears,
get a head, get a brain, like yes, I
understand that. But in the beginning
stages, if the circumstance is right,
there's there no one else should have an
opinion but that girl.
>> Okay. So, what I'm trying to say is that
even the justice system, right, the the
justice system thinks and knows that
that's going to be a double homicide.
Whether you're in your first trimester,
whether you're in 2 weeks, if they find
out and they do that swab on that
pregnant that pregnant person, they find
out she was pregnant, they're getting
charged for two killings, not just one.
So, if you're sitting here and you're
saying that it's just a clump of cells
and it's just a fetus, right? And the
justice system, right? Okay, now we're
going by the just the what we actually,
you know, go go with um is saying that
no, that's still two people. Whether
it's it whether the baby looks like
this, it's still two people.
>> So, if the if she was like one week
pregnant, would it still be considered
double homicide?
>> Exactly what I'm trying to explain to
you.
>> So, that's why I'm saying that I hope
and pray that this is something that's
educational for you that you can take
with you and look it up, Google it. But
just think about it. Why would the
justice system actually think that's a
double homicide if it's just this
little?
>> That means life matters,
>> right? Guess
>> I just have one question for you. From
woman to woman, if you got raped, would
you still keep the baby? I believe I
believe I believe that Yeah. I believe
that God.
>> Yeah. I believe that there's a purpose
for me like in this life. So if God
entrusted me with that, then I will go
with that. And if God decides right that
that's it's not for me then he will take
the life himself as a miscarriage.
That's right.
>> Amen.
>> All right.
>> All right man. Hey we having uh good
dialogues here on the street man. A we
man. Logic is God. Logic.